[Music]
in quiet cheering news oh that's like
the Japan Disneyland oh my god what are
the roller cause everyone's like
submitted by it
I love tight oh thank you we love them
too I'm a little half half with him
right I like his video nothing he's just
cute a university has replaced clapping
with jazz hands to help students with
noise anxiety what university is this
University of snowflakes oh I want to
guess it's a special one where this
there's special students like like
bouncing drum some kind of I will say
this though no their University I don't
[ __ ] care cuz I don't ever want to
cop ever I love clapping like following
it autistic down set like special kids
because like they're you know if they're
super sensitive you don't want them to
[ __ ] them like get all [ __ ] round up
and [ __ ] so this is that Manchester
University oh wow so it's in the Horn
land of the white people Jess's
ancestors whooping is also discouraged
what's up feels so good I know I guess
it depends on the circumstance if they
did this at a football game or soccer
game I think that's kind of messed up
cuz like if you have noise anxiety don't
go to a place that's gonna be loud as
[ __ ] but if it's like a classroom and
you're just there to learn and I bred
that I could see that's pretty [ __ ] up
golf tournament not a golf tournament
you supposed to cost like yeah not me
golf tournaments I'm all-in dude yeah so
it seems like they are doing like for
any school event like [ __ ] that I'll
leave that school the noise of applause
could trigger anxiety and some students
life
but they're saying that they're just
they want to be very inclusive and jazz
hands
the more inclusive I've heard about this
school I heard that if you fart you
actually are suspended to get the [ __ ]
last room I heard if you open a backpack
to learn the zipper go see did you get
expelled what about [ __ ] who is it oh
velcro wallet or you have to be in
seventh grade to get it and eat your
food like this in class like if you get
that perfect chip and then you put
saliva and just [ __ ] thaw it out oh
you have to smash with the roof yeah and
then you [ __ ] swirl it around and
drink it
these balls neither grow up and like
East LA where it's never appropriate to
have a gun shot in the middle of the
night or fireworks but if you get used
to it but I think other [ __ ] is okay yes
sir they're saying that they just want
to support those with disabilities or
sensory conditions to participate the
way that they can support them is to
slowly integrate them into society
instead of society bending for them
because what if they're driving and
someone wants to warn are they gonna
that's scary dude because the best way
to death I think deal with anxiety is to
slowly get yourself in whatever makes
you like anxious like big public places
whatever or like yet you could just
slowly acclimate to it yeah it's all
fear management and in the the more you
do it the more like the verified thing
where they're doing the virtual reality
they yeah faking being in like a tall
building but it's like putting them in
that situation so they could get the
sentence right because that can be that
can be dealt with it's not a phobia like
a phobia is really difficult right
because that's just some condition
that's just like making people terrified
[ __ ] oh what about like some of these
people that have like sensory like
sensitivity but though like physically
one percent should have country exactly
ninety person I know but I'm just saying
like maybe that you can't get over
because it's like physically you have
right yeah when we say these type of
statements though we're not talking
about that very small group you know
what I mean
so when people say general things we're
talking about the 99
but with but in that kind of case to
like everybody says that one statement
you have to say that now with every
statement now every time you say
something go oh but just in case not
we're not that including these it should
be obvious we're not including those
people you know what I mean
we're always talking about the general I
hate that nowadays do you always have to
have a disclaimer yeah and also that I
think that people with the extra sensory
sensitivity there's personal things that
you can do so that you know if you if
light is extremely sensitive to there's
a guy that went to military school with
light was extremely sensitive to his
eyes so he always wore sunglasses in
class he wasn't trying to be funny or
trying to be cool in whatever he always
wore sunglasses and in class and there's
like loud noises is too crazy they have
like those noise cancelling headphones
or it just equalizes the noise so if
someone whispers to you you can still
hear them but if they're going like that
it becomes a muffled clap to like the
things that you put when you go shooting
yeah like those like I think there's
like little things that you can just put
on and so it won't know they'll help
ease the anxiety if it is essentially
what I used to do it cause I you just
fall asleep I knock out dude oh I didn't
yeah I don't I don't really get it
because the way I see it is like if the
world is gonna be unpredictable and it's
gonna act a certain way right and I have
to figure out how to live in this world
like and then I can't always expect
others to accommodate for my needs like
I might then yeah best example is when
you travel right like when in Rome when
other people and whole tyre cultures do
it a certain way or like these people
believe this and then they're gonna be
loud and this group believes being quiet
or whatever you just have to learn how
to blend regardless if if it's scary to
you or not and then that's just how the
world works but if we're talking about
something extreme like people always
want to [ __ ] have a straw man
[ __ ] where they're like well what if
you know there was [ __ ] headhunters
and that's their culture they say some
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] like that and it's
like we'll [ __ ] you you can die I don't
care
that beam I'm just trying to help you
like I'm just trying to help you live an
easier life by trying to figure out how
you can control your personal conditions
and how you perceive things that that
makes it so much more easier than trying
to control whole entire groups of people
in society 100% agree to it and what
you're doing right now is that you're
setting yourself up for disappointment
constantly because you're expecting
everything to be perfect so when that
happens you're always going to be
disappointed perfect to your own
situation and it's just not realistic
dude that's just that's [ __ ] life bro
that's like the number one cause of
depression is like always expecting [ __ ]
and then not if it doesn't turn out the
way that you want it the whole world's
against the whole world yeah you're
always being let down all this [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] it's like man oh I hate this
kind of thinking it pisses me off I
don't I don't understand that stuff
nowadays I got unders I don't understand
why we're trying to cater to everybody
specific needs you don't even get that
in your own [ __ ] home with your
parents so why the [ __ ] do you expect it
maybe they do get at home maybe they do
have parents that economies you should
have never had yet and I'm gonna stop on
your penis yeah I'm wondering like how
many in fact though you want to stop I'm
sorry that's sack I'm wondering like how
many complaints that they got or like
how much outrage that they got that the
school has to change their policy it
might just be like from three people
it's not this it was the student union
oh you [ __ ] losers I'm picturing
something totally different from you
guys I'm picturing like a bunch of
students all getting together and
there's like the one person that might
be on the autistic spectrum or something
and they're all like let's do this for
Johnny like we're all gonna stop
clapping now like they're just doing it
like in a positive way there's so many
that've like you can't clap [ __ ] this
this is a safe space their picture of
being this militaristic like well I'm
not so picturing it I'm picturing a big
school like forty thousand people so for
me I'm just picturing if you have one
blanket statement let's like that like
it it seems like a school-wide policy
it's on a newsletter it's in emails it's
everywhere like hey everyone it's on
it's on the walls we're not allowed to
class
now we're not allowed to whoo-hoo and
I'm just like well you're stopping my
right to clap and that is able to just
need for me I'm gonna clap anyways how
about that what about during graduation
when everyone's cell oh I'm I'm whooing
and [ __ ] clapping when my best friend
got his [ __ ] white coat I screamed out
to the crowd that what's up Gandalf
white cult I said that [ __ ] I had to I
had to if I did not want to be the
friend and what if they have a foreign
exchange student program where they're
sending some students from the ghetto
and they use that foreign exchange yeah
what's for them right cuz then UK right
so if we send Americans that is foreign
we're stupid my bill right there oh I
forgot it was in the UK if you sent for
it like the Americans oven they're like
from the hood and they talk of every
[ __ ] clock that might cost depression
to them oh yeah cuz they need it dude
and I'll [ __ ] hate Americans yeah and
then everyone like changes all the rules
everyone needs to that girl's gonna be
crazy how am I supposed to get my point
across at mine clapping yo same but then
they cater to her later like what do you
want to eat
I don't know and they're not being
culturally sensitive what do you want
can't do it without it was your
confusing time man it sort of it so so
is it like effective right now yeah
video of this [ __ ] dude congratulations
to Timmy crazy [ __ ] losers yeah cuz
it's the same language for expression
for applause that's not even gonna feel
good can you imagine like let's say
you're a Bruin on Mars right any [ __ ]
kill it at this school every other
school you go to but then now you go to
this school and you're like well if
Brunel performs at this school he might
even have to like whisper perform with
no microphone yeah he screamed outside
person with auditory issues I mean the
auditory issue guy shouldn't be anywhere
it was like a specialist school I
wouldn't be weird right I know if all of
the all of the students that's the
majority now Chester universe's biggest
sounds like it's a big school like
there's sounds prominence [ __ ] man
Chester if it was like a special school
like I said in the very beginning and it
was bunch of like Oh
mystic or Down syndrome kids and then
they don't like noise because it like
rouse them up and they get all panicky
and scared and they're crying and [ __ ]
like I see that being a little bit
different yeah like people that are just
like going to college just chill in and
they don't have any disabilities it's
just extra sensitive and they have
anxiety or whatever it's like well learn
to live with it and get over it
[Music]